what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time but while
she's trying to get rich
the rest of us trying to get our lunch
money right
okay now we both have the uniform on
finally we're back
we are back to the basics in black don't
forget that lunch money is now sponsored
by blockfi
you can get a interest bearing account
8.6
apy in an interest bank account go get a
blockfly account block five
dot com slash pomp i was gonna say i
have the uniform on but i
have kind of a finance bro twist to it
i got a a vest on that's fully vested
blockfi.com pomp go get your account
today what's up
bitcoin broke through 18
000. ugh i woke up to that noise it's a
little bit below
18 000 at the moment but that's okay
it'll come back don't worry it's
popping over and under over and under
over and over do you want to do your
dance
nah oh yeah we could get a little no
problem all right
all right and it's already at an
all-time high based on market cap it
cracked 325 billion dollar market cap
which makes it
a all-time high there because of the new
supply
what's next oh god oh oh no internet's
not working
oh robin hood seeks advisors for a
potential
ipo next year i just want to know what's
the price what do you mean do you have
any financials in the in the article
um robin hood raised an additional 460
million dollars in a series g lifting
its valuation to 11.7 billion dollars
back in september
go ahead my lipstick is popping come on
come on you're saying a fashion show
so what are we saying what are we
talking about it has 13 million accounts
on the platform i think the ipo is going
to be really big if uh robin hood does
go public
uh i think it will be big for sure it
will be very interesting
interesting to see how well robin hood
continues to do
over time you know okay yeah
um softbank softbank's masayoshi sun
he's this og of oh geez he said on
tuesday to deal book at the conference
that
he is sitting on about 80 billion
dollars in cash
for investment opportunities and share
buybacks and vowed to stick
with his famously big bets on tech
companies he's continuing to deploy that
capital no he's sitting there deploy
that i know but he will
maybe the move into cash by selling some
soft bank investments is in part due to
concern
over the continued spread of the coved
pandemic i love masayoshi's song
i love his powerpoints they are fire if
you've never seen a softbank powerpoint
go look it up
what the hell is going on with this
little well you got alfalfa going on
the reason why masayoshi's son is so
interesting to me is
he was the richest man in the world then
he went broke then he came back
and again is one of the richest men in
the world he just takes
big swings the guy ain't seeing a risk
he don't like
i love it everyone's going to die take
risks who cares
go ahead i remember marissa meyer the
ceo of yahoo yeah i always liked her
i liked her too she except for that one
party i don't know what that was about
um she is back with
the launch of sunshine a consumer app
startup that is debut
debuting with an address book app that
relies on artificial intelligence
she's returning to the spotlight since
stepping down from yahoo ceo
after the company's 4.48 billion dollar
sale to verizon
so it's called sunshine contacts not to
be confused with sunshine
saks the pr company or sunshine what was
that one called reese witherspoon's um
company basically what it'll do is it'll
take your address book
uh and it will find and merge duplicate
contacts
it will fill out incomplete information
and continually keep that information up
to date
and it will also integrate with ios
contacts app as well as gmail and will
be free to all ios users with an
invitation
cool but like do we need this yeah i'm
about to go download this is awesome
really
yeah of course huh got to keep your
contacts popping up
no i want all the up-to-date information
what's their email what's their phone
number where do they work all that stuff
um so one of my former colleagues patti
sellers
gave us a great tip which i didn't know
existed
in your address book on in your contacts
when you click on a contact
there's a notes section so you can put
in
anthony's birthday as so-and-so and then
another like thing for every contact so
you always remember their birthdays
well you can do birthdays but the way
that uh she uses it is she basically
hey last time i met this person is x
time we talked about this
they've got three kids their kids name
our x y and z like it's a great way and
if you're going to do a call or a
meeting with them you just look in the
notes section real quick
so it's a very nice hack that's why you
watch lunch money all we do is we bring
you value
little hack right there use the notes
sections in the content
in the contact book in your phone you
can keep track of all the important
details
that are related to the people in your
book
what's up all right this is no
way it ain't him italy
italy's banksy as he's so
called referred to he's an artist
no this isn't banksy though i know he's
italy's banksy his name is gekko
a mysterious italian street artist often
referred to as
the country's banksy has been
taken into custody after an 18-month
search
um he's in rome and he basically uh
paints rome subway stations bridges
buildings and parks
infuriating the city's mayor he is
facing
they confiscated hundreds of spray cans
thousands of stickers
ropes fire extinguishers cords locks six
mobile phones
computers brushes rollers and buckets of
paint
like it's like contra my man was out
there he was
just spreading some joy and he could
face
some ridiculous hold on uh he's thought
to be in his late twenties originally
from rome
uh where is that and the environmental
police task force came after him
you all said the environment police
after him he's now facing up to two
years in prison
and fines and the residents are kind of
like okay maybe
you should fix and address the potholes
then infrequent garbage collection
and the economic toll of the coronavirus
pandemic rather than hunting down the
street
let my man spread joy let him spread
joy why are you guys trying to be
[ __ ]
i know tell that tell that to the mayor
all right it's ask lunch money time all
right we're gonna have to fly through
these there were some really good ones
all right let's go we're in a rush if
you can't tell us why we're talking fast
as if we're on like two next half speed
um all right this one's good will robins
what's up will
hey guys love the show question for pomp
sorry paulina no worries will
how has your experience in the military
served you in life and business
no worries if you prefer not to answer
are you gonna make me answer
oh why do you prefer it was the best it
was the best experience i had because
uh it did three things i went when i was
20 years old deployed to iraq
and it forced me to grow up really
really fast in terms of i was just
immediately immersed into an environment
with a bunch of guys who were much older
than me they had wives kids mortgages
etc
so it was a great maturity thing two was
uh it taught me the number one lesson
i've ever learned in my life which is
you're gonna die so go out and live life
enjoy it have fun
and just generally be happy so it was
worth it for that and then the third
thing is
i had the pleasure of going to a bunch
of leadership schools
in the army i graduated number one
obviously in the class
a fact but that was a really good
experience because
it essentially just taught me everything
from
the leadership skills needed in a
physical environment like the military
where everything's very authoritative
leadership
so i outrank you look i'm a sergeant
you're not you do what i say type
situation
all the way to uh situations where
there's more influential leadership
so you and i are peers how do i actually
help to lead
uh you and our colleagues to uh to get
things done
um so those are all great experiences
jared
salad bar asks what up jared salan bar
i have a decent amount of my savings in
bitcoin but i'm still in debt
if i were to pull out half of my bitcoin
holdings i could pay off roughly
three-fourths of my debt
considering how high bitcoin is at the
moment would it be smarter to just keep
holding
or so sell half to pay off the majority
of my debt
this is really hard to answer because
there's so many uh clarifying questions
and information that are needed
the biggest question i would have is the
interest rate on the debt
so if the interest rate is like two or
three percent then i wouldn't worry
about it as much because uh that's
pretty low
interest rate and what you're gonna end
up seeing is that the potential
appreciation of bitcoin will outpace it
um and therefore if you wait six months
twelve months you'll be able to
um kind of pay it all off plus have some
uh
some money left over but if we're
talking about like credit card debt that
is 25
30 then you absolutely should go pay it
off uh
uh immediately and so i think that um
you know
you gotta it's hard for me to give an
exact answer but a big piece of the debt
is just
what is the interest rate on the debt
and so the higher the interest rate the
more important it is that you pay it off
immediately
jonathan nading paulina how are news
journalists in today's society different
from social media presences that use
their platforms as a way to influence
the conversation
should journalists have greater
accountability to us than these other
influencers and if so how should that be
upheld much love you two keep hustling
yes so i come from a very purist
perspective when it comes to journalism
so i actually don't think
that journalists should be spreading
their political
beliefs on social media if they want to
be truly objective and have their work
taken
seriously and some of them do have
i believe a higher should be held
accountable for the things they say but
um here's here's my theory
over the last 10 years
a lot of media organizations have hired
younger much younger journalists
who were not necessarily taught by
purists they came from
sites like buzzfeed or the huffington
post or blogs or whatever
if you read there's a really good
profile feature right now
on the new york times in new york
magazine i think read that
and it'll explain kind of the great uh
generational divide
within the new york times between the
purists
and the much younger journalists who
want
more activism in the newsroom um whereas
i
i think that what you're getting at is
like they should be
accountable for the things they say if
they're going to be truly
journalists facts why has oh sorry only
one swami
why hasn't starbucks sponsored paulina
yet i know
um paulina what does your writing
routine look like for the profile any
tips on getting better at writing
besides write or ship more
yes you can be a better writer just by
finding
nuance in inserting nuance in your work
so instead of looking at the world as
black and white and using
words that are absolutes like everyone
no one always never
put nuance in the work and use language
that's precise
and gives a lot of detail sorry i just
picked ones that were for me
um okay if you kcs if you have a hundred
thousand dollars to invest you recommend
investing it all at once or do dollar
cost averaging throughout the year
for the most part regardless of what the
asset is you want a dollar cost average
i don't know about dollar cost averaging
over an entire year
you got to look at the asset what you
think kind of the investment thesis is
for the asset but dollar cost averaging
almost always is better
than kind of just a one-shot deal
uh but with that said i would do it on a
more compressed timeline than over a
year
all right and final question from erica
cassidy pomp you've mentioned certain
investments in private companies you've
made such as airbnb
how does one go about gaining access to
these types of investments
um so most of like the very large
companies
uh spacex airbnbs those uh were done
through spvs so basically i knew
investors that
were making an investment they were
looking for more capital and so i was
able to give it to some you know a
friend
and then they put the money in um but
the earlier stage companies so companies
like block fi
uh figure things like that that i've
invested in um those are
where we went out and raised money and
then we basically went to the founders
and said hey i'd like to invest in your
business
and we gave them the money directly in
both of those scenarios
you've got to be an accredited investor
which is [ __ ] but that is the rule
um and so what ends up happening is uh
it really is kind of this like super
disjointed inefficient market in the
private markets
um and it really comes down to kind of
knowing the right people
or meeting the founders when they're
fundraising or before they fundraise so
that you can get access to
those opportunities cool thank you guys
for the great questions i love
black on black on black on black back to
the basics we'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to point six percent
interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends